and that strategy
is reactionary
that means that
you stand there and do that
and he comes to grab and then you do
your technique
okay every time he does a strike
you then do your technique
so you're always after the fact you
understand that
he does a then you do b
right okay that's called reactionary
reactionary never works you will
if you wait your technique is not going
to work
no matter what art you're doing okay
in aikido we don't do the
obvious one afterwards so
in other words i go he goes and i go
here
and then i try and do the technique so
i'll show you he's going to do the
action
ready
do something
every time when he tries to counter
because he's moving after me
i'm going to be able to do something
else okay it looks like it worked for
you
in your training because what the
attacker did was they stopped
you see you see how i stopped i only did
one
but when i'm really attacking
i keep attacking got it
so you go okay that doesn't work so what
i'm going to do
is i'm going to attack first i'll be the
attacker every time
okay do you understand that so
he's he's gonna i'm just gonna attack
and then i'm gonna do
it see how that works and it looks like
it's pretty good
every time boom i just did
yeah okay
but that kind of makes you the aggressor
doesn't it
that makes you the bad guy in many ways
that's not what we do in aikido
so i'm going to feel his intention
and then at the level of intention
so in reaction i go ahead
and move at the level of physical
manifestation
okay so all we're going to do
is stand in range and when he's thinking
i'm just going to put my hand in his
face
okay and he has to change it so he can't
i don't want you you'd be that guy now
you'd be
uh you'd be knocking
i don't want you to go like this where
it's a rhythm because then he's just
following
a rhythm you got that i want you to
change it
you're leaning backwards already your
reaction
see are you leaning backwards oh
i can't keep track to relax
change the rhythm don't do a single
rhythm you got that
come back stop moving backwards
okay so just feel it and do what you
feel
okay get with your partner
okay so again i in english you can
you can call this a stockhead that's the
strategy i'm using okay so when
as he's about to strike you gotta slow
down solid everyone can see what i'm
doing
i'm hitting him i'm stopping his hit
got it it's called the stop hit all
right
and you could do it with anything
okay it does it's just about
interrupting
his intention so that i interrupt his
right socket got it yes
okay so when i do a stop hit i'm trying
to operate at the level of intention
i am trying not to be reactionary
okay so i don't lean back
and do it at the same time
obviously i don't let it get to the
level of manifestation
and then do it that's not going to work
so how much more difficult did i make it
when yo i'm doing this
and how effective is my strike when i'm
flinging backwards
okay and what was he going to do after
one strike
another one where's my balance
going back i'm gonna fall down
okay so
don't do reaction with your body
as well as with your block both are
going to get you into trouble
level here's the problem for the
beginner
juan you're not relaxed enough
if you're not relaxed enough you cannot
sense your own intuition
okay because you are in your tension
not actually here you are
in the last rep or you're in the future
red
so you cannot respond to what's actually
happening
so first thing you have to do is relax
so
to help us relax we're going to give
us what's making us freak out the
unknown is making us freak out
so we're going to bring some known into
it so he's going to
go back with that hand that foot
and now i know it's that side
okay we're going to govern uk's attack
it's the rear punch that's coming
through so when he punches
he has to do a step through you got that
okay and i have to do
the opposite hand so we're governing our
behavior we're bringing some more known
elements into it
it's always going to be that punch so
it'll be my cross hand if he has the
other hand
i know it's that one and i have to bring
my other cross hand in so it's like i'm
on me
you see cross he does that punch back
and i go right into the side okay
got that all right um
once you relax and i hope you can now
that you know what's coming
in you just don't know when okay
you're going to feel it
sometimes at the level of intention with
bad hook is
um you make them respond differently so
he
he feels it and when i when he sees my
hand there
he stops really quickly and it never
reaches the level of manifestation
and you're going to think you were wrong
you weren't wrong okay
if that was a real fight and the same
never reaches the level of manifestation
okay i'm still what did i do
i got him on his heels see and am i
going to strike one time
no i'm not going to strike one time so
when i come in i got his balance going
okay and i can do my things
so
we have to build a trust with our that
what some people say is like the hair is
on your neck or the butterflies in your
stomach
i don't know where you're gonna feel it
but when you feel it don't start
intellectualizing it got it don't go is
that it is that it is that not
it if you feel it boom you go
okay for the ukes to help cultivate this
in your noggin make sure that if you
have the intention
you throw the stride even if their hand
is in your face
you got it okay let's go so
i always couple my angle of attack right
angle of defense and my angle of defense
is always made up of two things
okay an angle of deflection
got it so he comes in i'll bring the
punch to the outside
but my hands going to the inside
so angle of deflection with the stop hit
so the two things are go the angle
deflection and you see the angle
deviation on my head i move it
out of the way forward into the side as
needed
if i don't need to if the angle of
deflection is enough
i will barely move my head
so he goes boom
oh
okay let's try so even though we're
working on the stocking strategy
i don't want you to i want to see
coordination so some of you are like
well he throw a fist and i was supposed
to broke this is now you're throwing a
fist here
you see that you're not in control of
your body
so the strikes are my strike stay there
just stay there like you hit me okay
the strike is palm heel strike and
you're going to bring
his eyes into your fingers you see that
so you have a poke at the end there so
i'm coming in
boom so my hand does this do you
understand that
so everybody's hand at the end should be
like that
but in the middle everyone should be
here
so it's one two it just this is his face
boom it goes right in got it i don't
want to see the eye poke at the end
i don't want to see the palm heel at the
i'm sorry i don't want to see the palm
heel at the end
and i don't want to see the eye poke at
the beginning
and i don't want to see that okay so
he's coming in boom
okay let's go
one i'm going to come down
and blend and do two being your boat
same side stay in the middle please okay
i feel him
boom please look like you're fighting
this way
okay so people see the attack pop
fingers and
one around boom
fingers
right foot to show the footwork
if he's let me have you aggress a little
more so you can see this punch the back
of my head
yeah don't miss punch the back of my
head
okay so we go boom
again punch the back of my head don't
miss
boom okay again
so well again watch that footwork i'm
going to slow it down now
you wanted to film
okay you see how he had that aggressive
energy coming through
so one i'm going to ride the aggressive
the aggression
with that step back to the outside and i
hit on the outside
everything of me is on the outside now
slow again
come to the middle please okay i feel it
but he has the residual aggression
right so i come back change the angle
you're going to want to make it two
moves one
two it's not it's a guy punching please
don't miss
one that's what you're doing okay
so he's punching
all right let's try it
you're sponsoring them like don't even
know who they are right
so so like i hear somebody's you know i
don't get the money it could be wrong
but
people right
this hand comes around grabs
here
around perhaps grab you have to grab it
see this comes on a second here
stop hit
don't lay on him your
your energy goes on the elbow
you understand not on you know i'm not
keeping him down
with that base i'm controlling his
shoulder
at the elbow okay if he tries to get up
my feet are usable
you see so you don't have your feet like
that you're not going to be able to use
them
so this leg is here this leg is here
okay to base out
usable face out not on him
over the elbow
watch your head
okay it's not a class on on roki all
right
oh it was the class on stop kids right
boom you could switch sides too right
okay however your roku blows
okay look strike to the face
strike to the face guess what's gonna
happen here
okay you guys are going like this
i'm going to use the rokyo
to hit his face on the ground
okay
what try and watch for that angle i'm
gonna do a little bit but i can't slam
his face to the ground
and uke's job is to not point his nose
at the ground
right so he doesn't get his nose broken
and he can kind of use that hand
and the counterweighting of his feet to
slow down the energy on his
face so between those those come that
combination of
i'm going to reduce the angle at the
last second he's going to turn his head
he's going to use his hand and he's
going to counterweight his head
we can do this technique
relatively safe
that's what i'm doing you guys have this
weird
okay so your angle is different than
mine one
two boom i have that
that angle but done with my body so i
don't have to break at the waist
so that's what i want with his head
though
so you have a video
so you can you can look at that one so
here we're going to do a multi
so i'm here like this
and okay has to move backwards like you
saw him doing
that
stop hit say beginning same
first part but you don't go down right
when you hit this bottom
boom you're gonna come around
okay don't drop come around
okay let's go
this hand goes down
my elbow acting as the full protein
okay so at the end the hand is above the
elbow
not even definitely not below
above the elbow we'll rewind the film
boom
okay tight i have my
initial when i come around with my body
okay but that's not my goal
my goal is the shoulder it's very much
like some
like santos
okay
you see how i put the shoulder down
rewind the film
see how i did that okay it's the
shoulder
okay so we're going to slow that down
even slower take some chemistry you're
not getting hit in the face too much
energy
boom down
here this angle first okay
this hand is irrelevant it's here
you can do this you can do this
okay you're going to just drive your own
wrist this is your rubber i tend to go
here
you're going to come up hip
rotate down
this back foot goes under you
you want
don't kneel down with it under her
it has to go under you so that that
doesn't happen ever
this is too risky under you
outside knee is up and her elbow
is against my ribcage i no no
you have to do a little more there you
go
so that's too much right did you see
that on her face
too much virginia one
step now
all right let's go
you will have the same kind of head slam
here if you aim for that shoulder so
when you come around
boom you're gonna have it right there
okay
right there you guys see that yes or no
right here
start with the almost that one
wow
you